let's go to hatred mail if you've never
seen hatred mail I'll remind you what it
is it's like a mandatory transvaginal
ultrasound for your mind Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America because freedom
today's hey treat male is related to the
Donald Trump campaign but also does
something that the Trump campaign often
does I'll explain after we listen to it
take a look
David honestly it's so blatantly obvious
you are so anti Trump you don't even
attempt to discuss him his spokesperson
or his campaign without total bias and
objectivity Katrina is one of the more
articulate spokespeople on anyone's
campaign that I have seen in this
election if he was so bad and she was so
bad then why does he have more votes by
the people than any other Republican in
history perhaps you should pull your
head out of your wooden headed
counterparts ass and nitpick objectively
on Hillary's campaign as well you
penny-pinching garage operation douche
bag this is unbelievable is there any
way Louis that you can put up just that
transcript just the the text maybe by
pausing the video when when we're
displaying it because I just want to
point out two things here to the
audience which are just amazing and we
know hey treats are known for just bogus
grammar and spelling and the entire
thing but there are two really really
funny things here that I want to point
to number one they're actually saying we
are objective in our discussions of
Trump they are saying you don't even
attempt to discuss him without
objectivity that means we are objective
in discussing Trump clearly the hatred
doesn't mean this but then here's my
favorite part
third to last line nitpick K NIT
yeah knitting like as in the act of
knitting a sweater
we are nitpicking objectively or not
nitpicking objectively on Hillary
Clinton's campaign so what's the analogy
here that's
Louis we don't need this anymore Donald
Trump chooses unwinnable battles all the
time going after a gold star family
suggesting that the opponent Hillary
Clinton maybe be shot by supporters of
the Second Amendment those are up really
unwinnable battles emailing me to defend
Katrina Pierson as the one thing you
want to contact me about the same
Katrina Pierson who defended a call for
a pure bead breed president the same
Katrina Pierson who says that so what if
we are hurting Muslims by banning them
from coming to the US after all they're
just Muslims this is picking unwinnable
battles and it's interesting that
supporters of Trump seem to be doing the
same thing Trump is doing choosing
battles that you cannot possibly win yep
it's a big mistake for Donald Trump for
Haiti it's it's just it's not really a
big deal
Pearson articulate yeah yeah well more
articulate than that Baumgartner really
Baumgartner yeah yeah there is one other
person that Katrina Pierson is more
articulate than and that is Trump's
other spokesperson Healey Baumgartner